[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
hatte geht's ein wackerer grundrezept
das habt ihr neulich schon auf galileo
gesehen heute gibt es ein ausführliches
rezept von mir und ich zeige euch wie
ihr ganz ohne backmischung arbeiten
können einmal kocher grundrezept habe
ich schon vor einigen jahren gemacht
aber mittlerweile habe ich da glaub ich
den dreh raus und kann euch noch ein
paar gute und hilfreiche tipps dazu
geben und sage euch hier mal die zutaten
fürs grundrezept nämlich 100 gramm
blockierte und gemahlene mandeln 120
gramm puderzucker 70 gramm eiweiß eine
prise salz 30 gramm zucker und etwas
lebensmittelfarbe passte wichtig ist
wirklich dass er hier schon bereits
gemahlene mandeln nehmt kein mandl mail
da fehlt einfach das fett und die
mandeln sollten vorher wirklich passiert
sein
die bekommt ihr so zu kaufen ich habe es
auch schon probiert die mandeln selbst
sortieren und dann zu malen aber dann
sind sie einfach noch zu fettig und
deswegen ist die trockenere konsistenz
hier auf jeden fall besser wichtig ist
auch dass das eiweiß nicht ganz frisch
ist also am besten wirklich schon ein
paar tage alt und wenn ihr wisst ich
möchte am freitag macarons backen könnt
ihr wirklich schon montags die eier
trennen und dann das eiweiß abdecken und
im kühlschrank noch mal stehen lassen
wirklich bis zu fünf tage dann gibt es
nämlich noch besser also mit ganz
frischen eiern bitte nicht arbeiten
das erste was sie jetzt machen müsst ist
mandeln und puderzucker noch mal
zusammen mixen damit einfach richtig
schön feiern wird und wenn ihr keinen
mixa habt lasst sie den schritt weg und
sieht das ganze nur ich mach das mal
eben im mixer
[Musik]
jesus die mandel puderzucker masse schön
fein und will jetzt noch gesiegt damit
einfach diese letzt mit klümpchen hier
verschwinden
und wenn ihr wisst dass ihr öfter mal
macarons herstellt dann könnt ihr euch
auch eigene backmischung machen macht
einfach hier von 356 siebenfache menge
tools ihnen glas ab oder ihren
verschlossenes gefäß und dann habt ihr
es einfach immer schon parat und habe
nicht jedes mal die mix arbeit und das
ganze 7
ich sehe das jetzt hier mit dem sieb
aufsatz von der kit steht aber ihr könnt
auch einfach ein hase
[Musik]
wenn ich ab und zu bringt es durchläuft
könnte folgenden trick machen einfach
kurz zu schließen und wieder öffnen und
dann fallen alle man dann mit dem
puderzucker schön runter
[Musik]
der erste wichtige schritt ist jetzt
getan und jetzt ist ganz wichtig dass
die schüssel gewechselt wird und eine
saubere und 14 schüssel nimmt für das
eiweiß jetzt gebe ich hier das eiweiß
rhein eine einhand rück gerät geht
natürlich auch könnt ihr auch benutzen
dann etwas salz und jetzt kurz schlagen
und dann hier langsam den zucker
dazugeben und nochmal für weitere zwei
bis drei minuten rühren
jetzt ist der schnee schön fest und das
ist auch die stelle an der jetzt der
lebensmittelfarbe dazu kommt falls ihr
die macarons gefärbt haben wollt und
dann nimmt er jetzt am besten
lebensmittel verpassten keine flüssigen
farben kein pulver am besten wirklich
verpasste
denn darf erinnert sich die konsistenz
der masse jetzt nicht
jetzt habe ich hier die gefärbte masse
die farbe wird übrigens intensiver wenn
die macarons lang gebacken werden und
nehmen jetzt hier die mandel mischung
erstmal nur etwa ein drittel
vorsichtig unterheben wirklich schön von
außen nach innen falten sowieso
unterheben
dann noch mal die hälfte vom rest dazu
geben und den rest dann auch immer
vorsichtig unterheben
da darf jetzt einfach nicht so stark
berührt werden aber trotzdem muss alles
nur schöne homogene masse und von der
konsistenz her ist die markierung masse
so dickflüssig ihr müsst mal schauen die
muss an einem faden runter fließen
das heißt wenn ich jetzt hier den teig
sauber hochziehen
dann muss ich eine kleine acht formen
können ohne dass sie abreißt und an dem
punkt dann einfach nicht mehr weitere
bisher brauchte man kein besonderes
werkzeug außer in hand rück gerät und
sie unten teigs aber jetzt braucht ihr
auf jeden fall einen spricht heute und
da fühle ich jetzt die masse ein
[Musik]
und hier unten habe ich am spritzbeutel
noch töne dran und jetzt nehmt ihr euch
entweder eine schablone eine vorlage die
gibt es bei mir zum ausdrucken und zwar
bis jetzt hier lauter kleine kreise mit
dreieinhalb zentimeter durchmesser wenig
einen drucker habt dann könnt ihr euch
die schablone einfach selbst herstellen
und hier jetzt schön aufspritzen
freihand könnte es auch mit augenmaß
aber ich mache immer ganz gerne mit
vorlage setzt hier an und kurz bevor ich
die dreieinhalb zentimeter erreichen
setzt sich ab denn die masse liegt
sicher noch ein bisschen
ich hab ja den vorteil dass wir die
schablone einfach immer wieder benutzen
könnt jetzt sehe ich das backpapier und
muss jetzt ein paarmal das backblech auf
die oberfläche klopfen damit die luft
entweichen kann und die macarons schön
flach werden
perfekt und jetzt müssen sehr an der
oberfläche erstmal trocknen damit sie im
backofen später dann diese füßchen
bekommen beim hoch backen
also dass ich sie jetzt entweder bei
raumtemperatur etwa 40 bis 45 minuten
stehen
oder ich kann das ganze beschleunigen
und faxe jetzt einfach hinten in den
automaten da kann ich nämlich den
vorgang beschleunigen
der automat zieht nämlich die
feuchtigkeit aus den macarons raus und
ich spare mir etwa die hälfte der zeit
aber hier mache ich jetzt noch zwei
drauf
die was sie noch drauf
[Musik]
wenn die makarov dann getrocknet sind
sehen sie so aus man kann man wirklich
mit dem finger auf der oberfläche so ein
bisschen darüber streichen
man merkt dann auch die oberfläche
verzieht sich nicht mehr geht nicht
kaputt und so dürften sie dann in einem
backofen bei 130 grad heißluft ich
wachse bei heißluft damit sie einfach
schön ihre farbe behalten nicht braun
werden die luft zirkuliert richtig schön
gleichmäßig und dann bekommen sie diese
typischen flüsschen je nach
raumtemperatur und je nach feuchtigkeit
in der küche oder im boden raum kann es
einfach sein dass er länger oder eben
etwas gehört zu trocknen müssen da
müsste einfach den oberflächen test
machen
[Musik]
die ersten macarons sind jetzt bei mir
schon im backofen die hier kommen jetzt
hier drücken
wir können doch keine zwei bleche
gleichzeitig backen vor allem bei
heißluft hat man halt echt im vorteil
und ich habe jetzt hier beide geräte von
bosch der hier ist allerdings mit dampf
funktion und er mit mikrowelle also es
kann wirklich sein je nach backofen dass
ihr mal länger oder kürzer backen müsst
und bei dem backofen hier ist es so dass
öffentlich einmal die backofentür lasst
die feuchtigkeit entweichen denn der hat
natürlich eine ganz starke dichtung weil
es eben eine dämpfung zucker und stärke
ist mit mikrowelle da muss ich nicht
machen aber wie gesagt kann auch hier
die backzeit so ein bisschen variieren
und ich zeige euch gleich wann hier
erkennen können ob die macarons fertig
sind
die sind schon fast fertig die
oberfläche ist fest aber sie lassen sich
noch nicht vom blech runternehmen also
noch ein zwei minuten und dann sind sie
auch gut
[Musik]
nach dem backen sehen die macarons sieht
so aus so finde ich sie wirklich perfekt
die haben eine schöne glänzende
oberfläche haben diese füßchen und wenig
sie komplett abkühlen lassen sie sich
auch perfekt vom backpapier ablösen
es gibt aber auch welche die bei mir
nicht ganz so schön geworden sind zum
einen liegt es daran dass ich zum
beispiel bei den gelben die mandeln und
die butter zucker macht nicht satt ganz
fein gemahlen habe da habe ich ein
bisschen ja da war ich ein bisschen zu
schnell
und deswegen sind die hier auch an der
oberfläche nicht so schön glatt und
glänzend
das ist ein grund aber ich muss sagen
gerissen sind bei mir keine das heißt
ihr müsst wirklich diese wartezeit
wirklich auch gut abwarten und die
oberfläche gut trocknen lassen dann
steigen sie schön hoch und es gibt
füßchen und eben keine risse und hier
zum beispiel sieht man dass die mandel
masse einfach noch ein bisschen zu fest
war das heißt dieser kleine spritze hier
oben dieser trend kann man da sagen
nippel oben kann man glaube ich der hat
sich nicht ganz geglättet weil es
einfach noch zu unterrot waren da hätte
ich wahrscheinlich noch zwei dreimal
rühren müssen also das sind so kleine
fehlerchen die passieren können
schlimm ist es nicht aber ihr selbst
lehne er sie perfekt macht dann haben
sie eine schöne glänzenden oberfläche
und die füße
diese schalen könnt ihr jetzt bis zu
zwei wochen einfach bei raumtemperatur
luftdicht verschlossen aufbewahren und
dann einfach beliebig film mit nagano
schmidt einer fruchtigen buttercreme mit
einer schokoladigen buttercreme ihr
könnt ja wirklich mal nach meinen basics
schauen marmelade könnt ihr ganz gut
einfühlen und dann müsste sie aber
gefüllt erst mal eine nacht stehen
lassen im kühlschrank damit sie schön
durch weichen
und dann sind die macarons außen nämlich
knusprig innen reich und wirklich schön
durchgezogen gefüllte macarons lassen
sich so etwa drei bis vier tage halten
je nachdem was für eine füllung auf
jeden fall gekühlt und ungefüllt könnte
sie auf jeden fall zwei wochen so bei
raumtemperatur lagern oder eben auch
einfrieren
ich hoffe ich konnte euch jetzt alle
fragen beantworten
ich mache demnächst noch ein video zur
rainbow macarons und sieben
verschiedenen füllungen das könnt ihr
euch auf jeden fall auch anschauen und
ansonsten wirklich auf meinem blog
vorbeischauen und schreibt mir gerne
welche macarons ihr als nächstes sehen
möchte also viel spaß nach backen und
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]